when I think about your father I think
about my father because my father was a
radio engineer oh and your law was and I
remember as a young guy I had read that
Stevie Wonder bought radio station KTLA
yeah exactly
I don't know inherit my father yeah he
hired your father to be what the
engineer the intellectually kids in
there did he have a first-class radio
telephone yeah he was the bomb he must
have been a very bright guy so he was a
genius he was genius yeah
and I'm telling you funny as hell
because he would hang out with Stevie
and the funniest story he ever told me
he was hanging out with Stevie and a
pretty girl walk by and Stevie was
looking at it and my dad did like this
he was like it was like a conspiracy
theory that Stevie can actually see you
get to hang with Stevie Wonder as a
young girl met him once I didn't really
go to the radio station a lot we did a
lot of the concerts and stuff like that
but yeah that's like oh he would meet
everybody like he met the barge and I I
was too scared to go cuz I loved him so
much right but then when he brought me
to picture where they signed it I cried
like a baby because I didn't go yeah my
brother's like you stupid you should
where you were too afraid to gonna be
like crazy